THE INFORMANT THAT SPIED ON
PAPADOPOULOS AND PAGE.
JOINING US NOW IS ROBERT GATES
AND MIKE TURNER -- MATT GAETZ
AND MIKE TURNER.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT I
HAVE WITH THIS IS THAT THE
MUELLER REPORT APPEARS MORE
LIKE THE DAY LIKE AN EXTENDED
OP-ED.
WE FOUND OUT ABOUT THE DOCTOR
THAT NANCY PELOSI VIDEO IN WE
FOUND OUT THAT THE TRANSCRIPTS
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LAWYER
JOHN DOWD, THE TRANSCRIPTS TO,
THERE WERE THE KEYWORDS
MISSING.
IS MUELLER WRITING OP-ED OR
DOING AN INVESTIGATION?
>> WE CONTINUE TO SEE CHINKS
IN THE ARMOR.
I'D POINT YOU TO THE GREAT
WORK OF JOHN SOLOMON WHO
APPEARS ON THIS PROGRAM THAT
POINTS OUT THAT MUELLER
IDENTIFIED AS AN INDIVIDUAL
CONNECTED TO THE RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE WAS ACTUALLY IN
THE STATE DEPARTMENT WORKING
WITH OUR GOVERNMENT.
SO IF ROBERT MUELLER WASN'T
ABLE TO ASCERTAIN WHO WAS
SPYING FOR THE RUSSIAN AND WHO
WAS REPORTING INTELLIGENCE TO
OUR OWN GOVERNMENT I THINK IT
WOULD CALL IN QUESTION
SUBSTANTIAL PORTIONS OF HIS
WORK.
BUT THERE IS THREE REAL LEVELS
OF WHAT MR. DURHAM'S DOING
THAT ARE IMPORTANT.
FISA ABUSES, THE LIES BEFORE
THE COURTS THAT SHOULD NOT
HAVE OCCURRED.
ALSO THE ILLEGAL LEAKS.
YOUR POINT ABOUT JAMES BAKER
HIGHLIGHTS THE EXTENT TO WHICH
UNDER JAMES COMEY LEADERSHIP
THE F.B.I. WASN'T CONDUCTING
THE INVESTIGATIONS AND LOOKING
FOR THE TRUTH.
THEY WERE TRYING TO SHAPE
PUBLIC OPINION.
AND I THINK MOST NOTABLY THE
CORRUPT ORIGINS OF THE
INVESTIGATION INSIDE THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE.
WHERE WE WEREN'T JUST
VIOLATING THE RIGHTS OF OUR
OWN CITIZENS BUT BRITAIN AND
OTHERS THAT WE COULD HAVEN'T
DONE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S BAD NEWS.
>> I WANT TO GET BACK TO
KOLINICK.
YOU ARE ON THE HILL AND YOU
SEE WHAT IS GOING ON EVERY
DAY.
DO YOU SENSE THE TIDE IS
TURNING FEELING ON THE HILL
WHERE THE DEMOCRATS REALIZE
THERE IS SOMETHING GOING ON
HERE?
THAT THERE WAS CLEARLY, THIS
WAS NOT, TO QUOTE SUSAN RICE
"BY THE BOOK F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION HERE."
LISTEN, YOUR COLLEAGUES UP ON
THE HILL ARE THE DEMOCRATS.
WE MAY NOT AGREE WITH THEM BUT
THEY ARE NOT STUPID.
THEY HAVE TO KNOW THERE WERE
SEVERE ABNORMALITIES HERE.
ARE THEY WORRYING THAT THIS IS
COMING OUT AND IT MAY REBOUND
ON THEM?
>> SOMETHING THEY WORRY ABOUT
IS THE AUTHORITY THAT BARR HAS
WITH RESPECT WITH THE
DECLASSIFICATION.
IT'S NOT THE OHR INVESTIGATION
BUT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
GETTING THE TRUTH AND THE
ACTUAL INFORMATION.
MICHAEL COHEN CAME TO TESTIFY
ON THE COMMITTEE I SERVE ON
AND THERE WERE LEAKS ABOUT
WHAT WAS IN HIS TESTIMONY.
THE STORY SORT OF CAME TO A
SCREECHING HALT THE MOMENT
THAT THE CRYPT
THAT THE TRYPT
THAT THE TRAPT
THAT THE TRANSCRIPT WAS
RELEASED AND PEOPLE SAW WHAT
WAS IN IT.
THEY MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE ORIGINS
OF THIS, WHICH I HAD TO LIVE
THROUGH WITH THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
THEY WILL FIND HOLES IN THE
STORY BUT THEY WILL RELEASE
THIS INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC
TO READ IT THEMSELVES TO SEE
THAT NOT ONLY WAS THERE NO
"THERE" THERE BUT THERE WERE
MISDEEDS DONE.
IT'S VERY OBVIOUSLY I THINK
CLEAR TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
THAT COMEY, CLAPPER, BRENNAN
AND BAKER WHEN THEY STAND ON
THE TELEVISION SETS NOW AND
ARE CLEARLY ANTI-TRUMP BIAS,
THAT BIAS PREDATED THEIR
LEAVING THE GOVERNMENT.
IT WAS THERE WHEN THEY WERE
OVER THE AGENCIES THAT WERE SO
IMPORTANT THAT WERE TAR GETTED
AT THE AMERICAN CITIZENS.
>> CONGRESSMAN GAETZ ON THE
POINT YOU MADE ABOUT KOLIMNIK
THIS IS DISTURBING.
WE FIND OUT THAT THERE WERE
SINS OF OMISSION HERE.
MUELLER I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE
WEISSMAN OUT OF THIS.
ANDY WEISSMAN, HIS
FINGERPRINTS ARE ALL OVER
THIS.
YOU BROUGHT UP THE FACT THAT
THEY DAMN MANAFORT IN THE
REPORT FOR THE DISCUSSIONS AND
WHETHER THEY ARE APPROPRIATE
OR NOT IS UP TO YOU TO DECIDE.
HE WASN'T CHARGED FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS BUT KOLIMNICK
WAS THE SOURCE FOR THE STATE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
WE FIND OUT THAT ONE OF
MUELLER CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMANTS IN THE CASE,
ALLEGATION, OF COURSE, BUT
APPARENTLY WAS ARRESTED FOR
THE CHILD PORNOGRAPHY OF ALL
THINGS.
THIS WAS MUELLER'S SOURCE?
THIS IS GETTING UGLIER BY THE
MINUTE.
>> THIS CONTINUES TO TREND IF
THERE ARE REPORTS THAT ARE NOT
DAMAGING TO THE PRESIDENT THEN
THEY TRY TO KEEP THAT ASPECT
AWAY FROM THE PUBLIC VIEW.
YOU SEE IT IN THE MUELLER
REPORT WHERE THAT INFORMATION
WAS NOT CAST IN ACCURATE
LIGHT.
BUT EVEN BEFORE THEN IN THE
FRAUD THAT OCCURRED BEFORE A
SECRET COURT WITH NO DEFENSE
ATTORNEY PRESENT YOU HAD THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
F.B.I. PRESENTING INFORMATION
THAT SEEMED TO INDICATE THAT
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS WAS
COLLUDING WITH ARE RUSSIANS
WHEN THE REALITY IS THEY HAD A
TRANSCRIPT WHERE BRITS RUN
INTELLIGENCE AGAINST
PAPADOPOULOS AND PAPADOPOULOS
DENIED EVER HAVING ENGAGED IN
THE UNLAWFUL ACTS.
SO, THEY ARE PRESENTING
INFORMATION TO TRY TO
REINFORCE THEIR BIAS.
RATHER THAN PUT FORWARD THE
INFORMATION THAT WOULD HAVE
SPARED OUR COUNTRY FROM THE 22
MONTHS OF DIVISION.
BECAUSE FROM THE BEGINNING IT
WAS ON THAT THERE WASN'T
COLLUSION BUT THEY ALLOWED THE
INVESTIGATION TO PERSIST.
>> DONGMAN TURNER, SO WE HAVE
SEEN -- CONGRESSMAN TURNER, WE
HAVE SEEN INFORMATION COME OUT
BUT VERY LITTLE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I'M THINKING OF THE BEST WAY
TO PHRASE IT.
I GET E-MAILS A LOT AND ON
TWITTER WHERE PEOPLE ARE
UPSET.
THEY SEE PEOPLE GETTING OFF.
THERE IS ALLEGATION OF A
SENIOR F.B.I. OFFICIAL ACCUSED
OF LEAKING.
AND THE D.O.J. DIDN'T WANT TO
PROSECUTE THAT CASE.
WHY DOES IT APPEAR IF IT
INVOLVES A TRUMP-ASSOCIATEED
PERSON, MIKE FLYNN, GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS, PAUL MANAFORT,
THE HEAVY HAND OF JUSTICE
COMES DOWN ON THEM HARD.
EARLY MORNING RAIDS, SEVERE
PRISON SENTENCES, AND PAUL
MANAFORT IS IN SOLITAIRE
CONFINEMENT ON RIKERS ISLAND.
I WAS A COP.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE ON RIKERS
ISLAND.
NO LESS SOLITARY CONFINEMENT.
BUT IF IT'S A DEMOCRAT THEY
SEEM TO GET OFF.
WILL WE EVER GET THE ACCOUNT
ACCOUNTABILITY?
>> INEQUITY IS TROUBLING.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND AS
YOU ARE AWARE FROM THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
CRIMINAL REFERRALS HAVE BEEN
MADE.
AS A RESULT OF THE INACCURATE
STATEMENT THAT PEOPLE MADE,
LYING UNDER OATH.
THIS WILL GO TO THE HEART OF
THE INCEPTION OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE PEOPLE AROUND TRUMP WERE
PURSUED FOR THE PURPOSE OF
TRYING TO TURN THEM AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT AND SAY THINGS
THAT ARE NOT TRUE.
MUELLER INVESTIGATION FOUND NO
COLLUSION.
THEY DID NOT CONCLUDE.
THEY FOUND THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE ULTIMATELY TO
CONCLUDE THAT THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED A CRIME ON
OBSTRUCTION.
BUT THEY PUT PRESSURE ON THE
PEOPLE AROUND THEM INCLUDING
RUINING THEIR LIVES AND
PURSUING THE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
THERE ARE CRIMINAL REFERRALS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE THAT WILL
GO TO THE HEART OF PEOPLE
BEING DISHONEST AND ABUSING
THE POWER AND BEING DISHONEST.
I THINK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILL UNDERTAKE IT AND THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC WILL GET
ANSWERS.
I THINK WE NEED TO CHANGE THE
LAWS.
>> LET ME FOLLOW-UP.
I UNDERSTAND AND I GET YOU
CAN'T GO OUT AND PHYSICALLY
PUT HANDCUFFS ON PEOPLE.
YOU ARE A LEGISLATOR, NOT YOUR
JOB.
YOU MAKE REFERRALS.
I GET THAT.
BUT THE FRUSTRATION IS, YOU
KNOW, IS THERE ANY PRESSURE
THAT WE CAN PUT ON THE D.O.J.
AND PEOPLE TO DO THEIR JOBS?
IT SEEMS LIKE THE INEQUITIES
ARE LEADING TO A REAL
IMBALANCE.
THE REPUBLIC ONLY MATTERS IF
THE PEOPLE HAVE FIDELITY TO IT
AND BELIEVE THAT THE
CONSTITUTION MEANS SOMETHING.
IT SEEMS TO MEAN SOMETHING FOR
ONE SIDE BUT MEAN ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE POLITICAL DEBATE.
MY QUESTION BETTER PHRASED IS
WHAT FROM YOUR SIDE CAN BE
DONE ABOUT THIS?
>> I THINK THE GENERAL
INVESTIGATION --
[OVERTALKING]
>> THAT WAS A FOLLOW-UP.
I'LL GO TO YOU CONGRESSMAN
GATES
GAETS
GAETZ FOR THE LAST WORD.
CONGRESSMAN TURNER?
>> IF YOU LOOK TO THE BARR
INVESTIGATION AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL INVESTIGATION, THESE
WILL GET TO THE HEART OF WERE
THERE LAWS BROKEN OR THE
PROCEDURES BROKEN?
IT WITH US NOT DONE BY THE
BOOK.
THERE WERE ABUSES OF THE
PRODUCT.
WE'LL GET DATA AND THE
INVESTIGATION FROM WHICH THE
INVESTIGATIONS CAN LEND
THEMSELVES TO THE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS HARDEST AND THE
REFERRALS FROM THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND THE
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
>> CONGRESSMAN GAETZ, LAST
WORD.
WHAT CAN BE DONE?
PEOPLE ARE GETTING FRUSTRATED
THERE.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
SICK AND TIRED OF A DOUBLE
STANDARD THAT SEEMS TO PAVE A
YELLOW BRICK ROAD TO THE
EXONERATION FOR HILLARY
CLINTON.
WHEN THEY WERE CLEARLY CRIMES
COMMITTED THERE.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME CASTING
THE ASPERGESES ON TRUMP
WITHOUT A BASIS AS A RESULT OF
BIAS.
THE ONLY REASON PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN THROWN IN JAIL IS JEFF
SESSIONS DID A TERRIBLE JOB AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
NOW WE HAVE A REAL ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
MR. DURHAM IS ON THE CASE.
THE INFORMATION NOW INDICATES
AT EVERY LEVEL OF THE
CORRUPTION WILL BE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND RESTORATION
OF THE JUSTICE AND THE RECALL